[Applause]
pick that little uh markup mate
so as they're sitting down
the next thing here just as they sit
down with a little bit of intro again to
try and keep you guys included we're
going to have a bit of a chat but
there'll be moments you can vote on
things so for those of you that
connected on on the wi-fi and uh scan
the qr code um
you can vote on things here
what topics you most interested in i was
discussing
your opportunity to just have some say
here and then we can make sure we cover
these things so as we do that let's do a
short intro
john i'm going to come to you first
um yeah tell us a bit about who you are
for people that don't know who you are
and then we'll kick things off
yeah cool no thank you for introduction
uh pleasure to be here so my name is
john hitchen i work for strive sales as
a sales manager uh we help sas vendors
at early stage scale their go to market
sales team uh we do it all across north
america and europe so
i've been in recruitment for about 10
years for all my sins and uh yeah
pleasure to be here tonight but amy
hi everyone
my name is amy steele i work for
coalesce management consulting which is
a
contracting consulting brand at amoria
bond and i'm the director of our
renewable energy team
so we look after projects in north
america and the emea region
also been in recruitment just over 10
years as well and boom the same company
the entire time so joined straight out
of uni
and
there we go yeah love it carl
hi everyone so i'm the founder of
orbition i've been in recruitment for
almost 12 years i think nice cracking on
now um
so yeah we do data analytics kind of
talent solutions across the uk europe
and u.s perm contractor consultancy okay
cool love it so let's just take a look
back here guys so we can see
what's coming up here so
we can we can take a mental note of this
so as we can see how to consistently
attract [ __ ] hot candidates
not surprised by that
how to consistently win great clients
and then we've got a couple the how to
grow my team business yeah okay cool
perfect so how we're gonna do this is
the sort of first half of this chat
we're gonna focus on
the current market what have we learned
in the last six months what smart
decisions do we think that we made at
the beginning of the year that have
played out why what are the challenges
um and then again we're going to have
something here that you can vote on so
you guys can share some of your
challenges make sure we speak about them
and then we'll then move on to talking
about the next six to 12 months not just
to shout about our there's a [ __ ]
economic downturn and it's all negative
we want to use this yeah we want to use
this time to hopefully just share
insight share how are these people
thinking about the next 12 months what
are they making sure their teams are
prioritizing and why um and also yeah
what decisions are they making that they
feel like are going to be decisions
they're going to thank themselves for in
six 12 months time so i guess to to kick
it off carl gonna come to you um talk to
me like what comes up for you when i say
like how how how would you describe the
last six months in in recruitment world
how would you describe that
difficult question for me to answer
really because obviously i'm
[Music]
an owner of a business right so i think
what i think about maybe slightly
different to what some of the audience
want to understand
i think it's been
record quarter after quarter for most
businesses so i think the market's been
really good as you'd expect um
not too sure
what more there is to say
other than that to be honest i mean it's
been it's been really good it's been you
know growth has been big deal after big
deal has been record after record um
okay
yeah amy have you had record after
record
yeah it's been it's been the same
actually i think everyone spoke about
the bounce back after covid and it's
been bigger than we could have ever even
imagined some of the results that we're
seeing from some of the consultants is
just unbelievable um
breaking boundaries of what we ever
thought was possible we've always been a
business where billing has been the
number one and it's an incredibly
competitive company and we used to have
like a handful of people in that sort of
500k plus bracket now we've got like
30 of the company or more in that
bracket going into this year just
because of how busy the market's been
it's absolutely wild we make a joke we
always call it the wild west but it
actually is
so john we're sick of hearing about
quarter after quarter so i'm gonna ask
you that question so
just prepared my answer
no so like yeah we can go on linkedin
and get that obviously so
what
what have been what have been the
challenges that manifested in in your
team from your perspective over the last
six months yes maybe you've had record
quarters as well but what have been the
challenges that you guys have had to
navigate
um it's a good question really um
i guess challenges from from a business
perspective like i think everyone will
know in manchester like it's a really
busy area for recruiters and
it's very competitive to hire really a
player recruiters as well uh we work in
a different business to these two guys
we're a bit of a startups we're about 25
30 strong and you know we're building
out l d functions now so
obviously we like to bring in people who
maybe have a little bit of experience um
so for us like a huge focus is obviously
hiring people and ramping them up and
giving them sort of everything they need
to support themselves and have run a
successful desk and
you know from an internal point of view
that's the challenge from an external
point of view like we've been quite
lucky really like
every year in recruitment it's a roller
coaster yeah no matter if it's a
recession or a boom really um you know
we've we've had
record breaking quarters we've missed
it's just um
yeah roller coaster
so
so obviously what people shared at the
beginning was very much things focused
on
winning clients candidate stuff so let's
get into that so carl i'm going to come
to you obviously as you said had record
quarters
fine but
what
all right
no
so i guess what i want to find out from
you is then if if you have what has
consistently been
like the number one thing that's enabled
you and your team
to attract candidates to have the best
people that you're working with to speak
to your customers about because there's
no way you're doing those numbers in the
record quarters unless you get very good
at that so
like what have you found amongst your
team to continue to work when it comes
to attracting candidates whatever that
may be what does that look like in your
business
so again probably
a little bit different because we're
still start up right so less than
two-year-old so to have a record quarter
is not probably
a massive thing but you know um
hey just i'm just being honest i'm just
being honest right but um look
the business has done really well i
think
the biggest thing that we've probably
focused on around canada attraction is
multiple routes to market okay multiple
channels in terms of how you're trying
to go about attracting these people um
in any boom market obviously most
candidates are being
hammered non-stop so one of the things
that we've
had a big focus on is looking at
how do you articulate a message that
gets a response
ultimately like what what's the
compelling narrative and i think we we
have a big conversation up front with
our clients around understanding what
that is from their perspective
because ultimately you know these
projects that they're trying to deliver
whatever that may be they're as only as
successful as the people you've got in
situ
you've got to have good people to do
that to get good people you've got to
have a good story so i think
recruitment's probably been lucky in the
last
12 months or so that it's been a boom
because most recruiters have had the
chance to pick and choose who they work
with and people who've had the most
compelling stories but i think that
multiple channel multiple approach
creating a narrative that's like
important but how you articulate that
and deliver that that's been the big
thing that we've probably had what would
you say the principles end up getting a
response
i don't think there's a
one-size-fits-all for that mate i think
it's understanding the particular role
that you're working the company you're
working for understanding your audience
are you trying to
attract what makes them tick and
articulating the narrative whether
that's message whether it's an email
whether it's a phone call whatever it is
getting to that point of getting them
hooked because
ultimately you know they're going to be
10 15 messages a day probably right so
it's how do you cut through the noise
yeah yeah and then just just quickly
because so you when you said
multi-channel
what does that look like so we were
doing a bit of training on this actually
today so obviously you know you've got
linkedin you've got your email campaigns
with source well you've got your crm
we're talking about utilizing things
like github or twitter or
whatever the case may be right you know
if you if you narrow your search down to
the top 10
they're the people you want to get hold
of
are you going above and beyond to get
hold of those people because that's
normally the difference between win or
lose
and then john let me come to you then
what like looking internally what would
you say has been the most effective way
that you and your team have consistently
had a positive flow of candidates coming
through that pipeline that you've got
people to speak to your clients about
what does that look like at strive
yeah now good question so we recruit
sales individuals um so i think for us
in the industry they can tell what we're
doing and they they know our approach
they know what the first cold call
contact looks like and
they're probably assessing our
objectional handles so
for us uh similar to kyle really like
you know you look at those top ten
percent of candidates for the job um you
know who meet the brief
and put them through a number of
multiple touch points and
linkedin text messages phone calls
emails uh we do something a bit
different with video headhunting as well
it's like personalized videos which has
been been great like our
um
our reaction rate to that has grown
significantly yeah and you know
obviously when you cold call their email
it's like single digits and this is by
far double digit sort of candidate
attraction so that helps us get those
little pockets of candidates which our
competitors can't um and then hence
obviously ends in a bit a lot of value
to our clients i'm going to put you on
the spot here
i'm not going to ask you to do like a
video
i had three bears mate
no that'd be savage what again i'm going
to ask you because like people would be
interested okay okay you might use audro
hint of you you might use videos you
might whatever whatever video tool that
you use
like again i'm sure you work your team
with this what
what what is like the core thing these
guys here need to get right when it
comes to video outreach like because i'm
sure this is a constant thing you
improve on but
number one piece of advice when it comes
to video outreach and and nailing that
do you think
yeah no a really good point um so
obviously when you do your video um you
know make it super personalized i think
just
if you if you're making a video it's not
even got the name in it or it's not on
their profile the whiteboard a little
whiteboard a little whiteboard you know
john
you know telling them a little bit like
a lot of your experience from x y and z
or whatever it is um i think
personalization is key in that and you
know as soon as they watch the video
it's about keeping engagement so like
what format are you going to use on the
video to ensure you've got a structured
script and that it gets to your call to
action at the end so
process and personalization is key there
nice thanks sharon uh amy i'm gonna i'm
gonna ask you to share a bit about the
the bd side i know when menu recorded
the podcast that seemed like a really
strong area
for you like you said you've got people
in your business getting to the crazy
numbers more quicker so how how have you
made sure that they've remained
motivated to
still make time for business development
still get on the phone to speak to great
clients and those things like how yeah
how is sort of your team's motivation
around bd played out if they're doing
record quarters and things are going
well how does that look
i think because with my business
division it's effectively contract yeah
you could get a termination out of the
blue at any time so you're constantly
chasing your tail on your runners and
with a contract business you have to be
prospecting every single day no matter
what i know with perm you're effectively
starting at zero every single month and
there's an argument to say when you've
got a contract book you know what you're
billing you know what you're being paid
regardless but actually the the contract
jobs they are a little bit fewer and far
between particularly
these high-level projects and you have
to have the discipline to say no to a
perm job or say no to a job that's
outside of your core market because
you're never going to really become an
expert and a specialist and make your
job easy for yourself where you can
redeploy candidates and you've got
people coming to you because you really
are the go-to person so with with my
team we put a strategy in place around
the type of calls that we're making so
we use the candidates that we've got
either the ones that are coming off a
project that we need to redeploy onto
something new so ring competitors sell
them in and say they're coming off a
project on this date you know are you
interested and
again because it's all about the
technical piece with us we take
references on everybody because we're
just measured purely on the performance
of our contractors that's it really and
it's a lot more transactional it's it's
although it is a really in-depth service
a client doesn't necessarily see it that
way they see it as more outsourced so
the way we're judged on our service is
really the quality of the contractor
that we've got on site so we reference
everybody and that's a business
development call in itself so we'll flip
that book as many meetings as we can
follow up contract leads and we have to
be really really tight on leads because
the jobs are fewer and far between most
clients do want perm people you know
that's that's the reality and it's
really easy to slip into the trap of
thinking i'll just pick up a few perm
jobs but
you can't do it you're running that
subscription model you've got to stick
to it so you need to follow up your
leads take your references book as book
meetings with as many people as possible
and provide a bespoke solution to that
client based on what they want it might
just be manpower they might want
mobilization materials all these other
parts as part of it but i just say to my
team all the time there could be a
better client out there and every client
has a shelf life it's sad to think that
but they do at the end of the day it
always makes me laugh with recruitment
because you do a really good job for a
client and you place lots of people and
suddenly they want a discount so you're
almost being punished for doing a good
job but you have to explain to them you
know every person is unique it's not
like you're manufacturing a part when
the volume goes up it's cheaper for us
it isn't and eventually clients always
get to the point where they want a
discount or they want to try a new
supplier so you've just constantly got
to be prospecting all the time because
there's always a better client out there
what's like the the go obviously hear
that a lot what's like the the go-to
strategy on like flipping a reference
call like because that's yeah so
i think the key thing with the reference
is you're subliminally selling your
service by taking the reference anyway
because not everybody does that and then
at the end of the call it's you can say
look we obviously work in the same sort
of areas we supply people or we deliver
on projects in the area that you're
responsible for i think it would be
really beneficial for us to meet and
discuss further how the two businesses
can work in partnership and because it's
a pretty warm call they don't really
realize it's a sales call
more often than not they're very keen to
meet you and it's so easy to jump on
teams or zoom these days um i get my
guys to attend like 15 20 meetings a
month minimum
just to keep that new business flow
coming in
nice and then call what how how things
manifested for you then what's been the
most consistent and effective way for
you guys to winning great clients and
do well on that side
um so everything's brand related for us
yeah we have a very big push you know
marketing relationship content brand so
obviously the podcast
the events stuff like that and it's it's
not too dissimilar to what amy's just
said about you know reference calls and
flipping it's the same
it's the same method you're just talking
to them about something different how
does that actually play out then for
people because i think a lot of people
can be cynical about that right just
keep seeing you posting on linkedin
thinking [ __ ] how is this going to
shut up does he not talk stop talking is
it just to benefit himself like how does
it actually play out
how does it play out for the guys like
how does it how does it help you guys
stand out when it comes to bd that you
got you have a podcast or you have a
round table series or whatever like how
does that actually play out well the
reality so we did an exercise on this
mate as a business so all the revenue
that we've had from when we started the
business has come back it's 100 inbound
to us
now that's been
instances where we've instigated that
relationship through the podcast or
through an event or whatever the case
may be but ultimately there the client
is the aggressor in the relationship
so
we have a big focus on
like community communities our thing
like adding value back to the community
so soon you know and i think that's you
know we'll probably get into this later
on but i think that's the way
it's going yeah um
and
as soon as you start to to do that you
know you again subliminally selling what
you do you know it gives you an
opportunity to be credible to sell what
you do without it being like a sales
call
and then john coming to you then same
sort of question like
when it comes to effective bd what
what's continued to play out for your
guys what's continued to be the the best
most fruitful activity if there is one
what what's played out for you guys
yeah it's one of those things in it like
bd is so huge in recruitment but i think
when we we sat down particularly you
know adam and harrison who are who the
business owners drive like we just
identified that there was a certain type
of client we did really well with okay
um and in our industry like if you look
at it broadly there's thousands and
thousands of clients and when he starts
like zone into your tier one client like
what where am i going to get a return on
investment and then just map out the
market from there and obviously add
value to them and
do everything these guys have said
whether it's flipping a reference
whether it's specking in whether it's
cold calls and
adding value in any certain way so we
just kind of found our sweet spot early
on and been able to sort of really
target it so yes you really focused on
like yeah the clients you can serve most
the clients that you have the best
results with and then focus your energy
on that
yeah yeah exactly that and it's done
really well and then
we're really fortunate in our industry
that we can carry that over into
different continent um we can just
expand the client so
you know maybe one day we'll get to a
point where we want to when we branch
into a new market and it's like doing it
completely again but there's a there's a
few sectors we work in and we work in a
really exciting industry so it's
we're zoned in now we know where we're
going
so carl and i come to you on this
question this was submitted by someone i
think it's an interesting one and maybe
a challenge that has manifested in the
last six months so
how how have you balanced the
recruitment needs of your clients with
the head count on the business to
fulfill those requirements like i feel
like it could be easy to
be like
what's that said lol
like how do you because i feel like
yeah you you yeah you might have
experienced a lot of opportunities big
business but you're thinking are we
actually able to [ __ ] deliver on this
yeah 100 so everything that we do
typically is done at scale so everything
is retained in some way shape or form
and it's normally project led so even on
the perm side so
you know it might be five hires
immediately it might be 20 hires over
the next 12 months and obviously that
from a business perspective poses a
challenge because
you know oh it takes one call you're
onto something then all of a sudden
you're like [ __ ] you know i've got
20 hours to deliver and not enough
people so that's that's probably been
one of the biggest challenges in terms
of
you know growth as john mentioned
earlier about trying to hire people
internally that's that's always a a big
challenge but have you have you said no
have you created a waiting list have you
said like
for clients yeah they're they're all
waiting outside
but like how have you yeah how have you
juggled that yeah you just had to do you
know where the limit is
um with the reason so we
there's been things that have been in
the pipeline for a while that we've
purposely not
gone after that aggressively in terms of
us following up you know conversations
where the client's saying
yeah we're interested in this type of
project or proposal and you know we'll
we'll send a proposal and then we're
happy to sit on that for a couple of
weeks while we wait to clear off some
work um obviously the team's growing
taking shape
you know that stuff's now starting to
really take over so um
but it's like anything right the
the more you grow just
the more you win
the challenge never goes away it's just
a bigger scale so okay
so
another question which i think links
quite nicely into this amy i'm going to
come to you on this i don't know how you
feel about this with your experience but
like what would you say
what was shared was what would you say
would be your like top tips best advice
when it comes to
um expanding existing accounts i don't
know if that's something you really
drive within your team but like again
how have you gone about if you're
looking at your current client but right
now what have been the the best ways to
get them to spend more money with you
and create extra revenue streams like
how how is that played out so i think
the first thing is you've got to provide
an exceptional service ultimately our
product is people so you have to get to
the best candidates in the quickest
space of time and manage that process
and streamline and as effectively as
possible because if you're not going to
do that
you're not doing your job properly so
that is absolutely priority number one
once you've done that it's about getting
testimonials from the people that you've
worked with getting borrowed authority
for them to go to their colleagues and
say i've worked with this supplier
they've done a really good job for me
you should try them
i've always been a really really big
believer in meetings okay um and that's
something that i really drive home with
with my team as well and as a business
actually it's a huge thing that we do
and i think getting face time with
clients is absolutely invaluable to
building relationships and understanding
their business
and so i think a combination of
networking via service
meeting lots of people
getting your contractors or even the
people that you place permanently to do
the work for you
referring you into their
their colleagues as well um and we do a
lot around like market mapping as well
so
if you place with one client where are
the other sites whether they're in the
same country or whether they're abroad
map them out because it's a much easier
call to ring somebody and say we've
placed with you we've got terms with the
business than ringing a completely cold
prospect so trying to be as strategic as
possible with what it is that you're
doing as well nice
journal i'm going to come to you on that
one what what comes up for you what do
you consistently find
amongst your teams in terms of like the
clients that have gone from spending 100
grand a year of you to 300
yeah sorry i got absolutely distracted
then
yeah now this obviously
that's about to take a picture hey
cheers guys
it's basically going to take two more
photos isn't it
that's right mate
[ __ ] hell
one second i'll be right back
[Music]
you can turn that back off
um yeah no is that done oh there's one
more
wow right
so yeah sorry
john what are we saying expanding
existing accounts what what tends to be
the most effective way for you and your
team do you think yeah now it's really
good question i like what amy said um
obviously mapping out the market as well
and and sort of going into everything
wow
um i'll just carry on for the sake of it
you gotta kind of look at it two ways
like you've got your current client base
and then we look at it from two points
of view so like a strategic point of
view okay so what's gonna happen with
this account over the next three six
nine twelve months yeah what's the plans
for us what's our objectives how are we
going to do it and i guess the second
way of looking at is like tactical okay
so tactical stuff is going on now what
jobs are they live what are we working
is it contingent
retained exclusive yeah how are we
adding value and how we're going to go
from there so
like getting into accounts and expanding
them is like short term and long term so
there's two different ways to look at it
and then on on the on the
get that on the long term piece just
interested like what so if you get into
an account you do a good job make a
placement or two placements what key
things are you looking for that indicate
to you and your team that right this is
a count could one could definitely be
someone that's yeah giving us five ten
fifteen twenty jobs a year what you said
on the strategy so what sort of levels
or things that you look for yeah now
again good point so like i think
everyone's opportunistic in recruitment
we all want to do well so you know we're
all beating with like an upfront
contract so like give me this job on
whatever basis if i fill it what you're
gonna do your next three hires come to
me exclusively so kind of making that
upfront contract with the clients
locking them in from an early stage
um and then obviously looking at the
different
parts of the the business that we can
address the market mapping maybe that
yeah
yeah exactly like and i think what amy
says as well like she was like zoning on
you what you do like don't go off
two-piece too much because you go down a
rabbit hole and maybe sometimes you
think you can do everything whereas if
you're just adding value into the
certain sector you recruit into you're
gonna you know get all the candidates
generate with the candidates put them
into other businesses so you kind of
become your niche yeah okay
so um
what we'll do then is i i i want us to
the next segment just to talk a bit
about how i think i've spoken to a lot
of people and a lot of people submitted
questions around how are people feeling
in the next 6-12 months all those types
of things but i guess
before we do
what i've tried to do here is i guess
just create an opportunity for you guys
to share with us like what are some of
the challenges that maybe we haven't
even touched on here again to try and
make you guys feel included when it
comes to the discussion and what we're
talking about so if for those of you
that are connected to the wi-fi there's
an opportunity here just to share um
with us what what have been or what are
some of your biggest challenges
currently
and then depending on what plays out
here we can have a bit of a chat
um what's that can't see so yeah
and then yeah this this will play out
into the the next 6-12 months as well
we can see if we're surprised by
anything
i'm gonna
i'm gonna come to one here so amy i'm
gonna come to you on this one
not having consistent performances each
month
what like again i know you said you
like you yeah like your team have been
doing really well
but again you've been in a game for a
while
when it comes to looking at people
looking people you've managed
like what do you think are some of the
the things that
you see when it comes to people not
consistently performing each month what
are the common things that you see when
someone has a really good month two
months they don't then the next month
they do
yeah i mean it's sales isn't it so it's
not always going to be plain sailing but
the the big thing that i look out for
and what we talk about all the time is
like the w effect so like good month bad
month good month bad month because
you're never gonna really really
progress if you're doing that
i think not getting complacent
is obviously really really important you
have an amazing month it's like i'm
smashing it feet up
the best best performers never ever get
complacent they just always always want
more and i think having the discipline
despite how well things are going to
still do the basics every day to still
hit the numbers every day that's what's
going to take you from being a great
recruiter to an absolute top biller and
that's what is going to mean that you
might have one bad or two bad months a
year not four or five
um how do you spot complacency oh it's
so easy getting in a little bit later
leaving a bit earlier
phone time's not as high
being cutting corners a little bit on
process
you can spot it a mile away you can see
it really really quickly and actually
all it takes is a quick chat with
somebody and often
they know it themselves and
they're straight back in line again but
it's actually
recognizing it and doing something about
it for yourself and your business that's
the important thing because when you're
thinking about top performers or
consistent sales people yes you've got a
manager and a leader but ultimately it's
got to come from you we're here to
support to motivate
you know to challenge you at times but
it's your desk it's your business you've
got to have that burning drive desire
ambition discipline to do what you need
to do every day because nobody's going
to pick the phone up for you okay
so
thanks for sharing that that's awesome
um john i want to come to you on this
one so
um i think we've spoken a bit about carl
shared a bit about the way that he's
gone about attracting candidates and a
few different things but
candidate management
like i have you have you guys been
experiencing the because of how busy
it's been
you headhunter candidate and and these
people have several options
um and yeah i speak to so many
recruiters that are having more dropouts
than they ever had and these things so i
guess what comes up for you when it
comes to thinking about again you and
your team you and you guys internally
what are some of the things that you've
really had to get sharp on when it comes
to candidate management and again those
people are an offer but actually having
these people start and do that when it
comes to candidate management because
obviously a lot of these people are
spoiled for choice
yeah and a good point um i think
something typically recruiters are
really good at is getting happy ears
i've got a candidate in process i've got
a deal like you know it's never the case
like we all know it's you know five six
seven interviews before the job's boxed
off in perma obviously contract's quite
different
um so i think it's about understanding
like is a short list filled what are the
quality candidates like and something
we've introduced into strive lately is
like um
a deal risking methodology okay so we're
looking at different aspects of like the
candidate we're risking whether we feel
they're gonna get the job the reality is
you have to sit down and say if if half
of the shortlist really aren't
interested in this job or they're
interviewing in five or six different
other processes then we need to do more
work on it okay because what you don't
want to do is get to a point where you
think this job's boxed they'll take on
two more
then you've got to go back to it and
work that and before you know it you've
got too much to handle and then
something slips so
i think just focusing on happy years and
then deal risking is like a really
important sector deal risk framework
what what are some of the
i have to give all of them obviously but
like what what would be some of the
things that you would go that deals at
risk of interest because i think people
would be interested in that
yeah yeah um
so i think like to the obvious ones like
money yeah so candidates who are like
really money oriented and money hungry
like i don't care where i work or what
to do it's just
who's going to pay me the most and i
think it's also important to look at
like what other processes these
candidates are in
getting them to rank those processes and
understand from your point of view like
how how likely are they to sort of rank
this better than everything else okay so
if you're just looking at those two
first of all it's a really good starting
point because
i think it's something we've all got
guilty of is getting to a certain point
thinking yeah it's done this and the
reality is it isn't like we probably got
a little bit sloppy nice
so let let's talk about
let let's segue here let's talk about
the next sort of six months or so khan
and come to you first
been in been in the game for a while
what are we saying what how are you
feeling about the next six months let's
just start there like
what's top of mind
so i'm mate personally i think there's
um feeling pretty positive i know
there's a lot of murmurs about a
recession and all this kind of stuff but
we've not heard a great deal you know
hopefully in six months time i've not
been proven wrong and i'm looking have
you have you found things slowed down
not slowed down
no not really mate outside you know we
work with some clients that are like you
know maybe
private uh private equity backed you
know so like series a startups for
example they've
paused a little bit um
more just out of caution but okay other
than that you know look you know we're
still having conversations made about
taking on 30 40 50 man retained projects
over the next 12 months so so overall
feeling positive
amy how are you how are you feeling yeah
the same to be honest i think we're in
very carefully chosen sectors so
my old division was engineering and we
made the the strategic switch because we
had to
we've covered so renewable energy is
it's the perfect storm really it's
government-backed but privately owned
businesses that need to make profit so
you put it both together and then the
entire world's got like a green energy
target it's not really a case of like
spend or not it's we have to do it
because we've pledged that we're going
to do it on a political level so
i feel like again same as kyle i hope
i'm not proven wrong but so far we're
not hearing of any sort of slowdowns or
anything like that so i just hope that
it continues
jon
uh yeah no i was speaking to adam today
he's been in the tech sector like quite
a lot longer than me um and i think we
can all agree and tech like last year
was probably the best year of
recruitment we've we've ever had like
undoubtedly um especially on the back of
2020 so
probably will be a little bit peaks and
troughs but i think so if you've noticed
things lined up it's like obviously
you know i've seen things it's it's a
bit of a niche right now actually oh
we're telling the guys in the monday
sales meeting that there are still an
abundance of jobs in the market
some organizations have let staff go so
that just means there's more candidates
and more jobs in the market
might be different in three or six
months but the reality is right now
there's
you know if someone says to me oh
there's a recession i can't fill a job
like bollocks really it's right this is
a good time
so amy i thought this is a really um
interesting question that got shared and
i'm gonna come to you with it first i
guess what what decisions then do you
think we can make as recruiters
recruiting professionals which a lot of
the people here are
um what decisions can they make today
that
um they they feel like they'll thank
themselves for in six months time like
what is it that they need to prioritize
keep prioritizing focusing on
the uh yeah they're gonna give
themselves a nice pat on the back in six
months time and be yeah best protected
best prepared
no nobody knows what's going to happen
like and you can only control what
you're going to control what you can
control so
i think it's just about doing the basics
properly no matter how your business
operates we as a business we're very
numbers and kpi driven and it's not
right or wrong all the businesses aren't
but whatever it is that you're told to
do that works and works for your
business work the metrics work your
ratios
best practice the basics do it
consistently every single day
and
the deals will look after themselves and
in six months time you'll look back and
be like i'm really glad i did that
groundwork now
because it's starting to pay off
how do you i know everyone says that
like back to basics
how would you describe the basics
i think just when you rebound right back
to the beginning of your career and you
taught how to do the job not cutting
corners every time you speak into a
candidate gathering information
in terms of other projects job leads
references current managers
when you're speaking to clients
objection handled properly you know map
out your market effectively and
be as strategic with what you're doing
as possible make your life as easy as
possible and if you know what works for
you i always say to my team you know
pick something that's your thing
obviously you've got to do a little bit
of everything but what is your thing and
really master it and really push
yourself on it i said i think i said
earlier mine was meetings i knew that i
could get in front of a client i'd win
that business so
i used to just double the target for
myself so pick your thing master it and
stick at it really lean into that yeah
um
i'm going to come to you with this i'll
honest i want to see what you say
this is like a really like negative
potential outcome
just see how you'd react
um so if all your clients stopped hiring
tomorrow
what what would be what would be your
game plan what would be your approach
where where would you start where would
you go
i'd let all them in there waiting at the
door mate
now you can come um for now yeah some of
you some of your key accounts said carl
really sorry we've had an absolute
[ __ ] mayor we had to let 50 of our
team go got no budget agency spend done
what we done what would be the approach
so i think um obviously our approach is
very different to a lot of other
businesses approach like for me
i think you double down on community
okay like i
think i i personally think that's where
the future's going that's why that's why
we operate the way we do again it's not
right or it's not wrong right but if you
are
if you're creating communities of people
within your target audience whether
that's client whether that's candidate
right and you can add value to them in
some way shape or form and you're
visible with that right
that's where
that's where success comes from in my
opinion right i think that's that would
be the stuff that i would probably do
even more of at that point because
you know
as we all know right recruitment's
crowded it's saturated even in the more
niche markets there's now a lot of other
players it's like you just need to be
known as the player
simple as that
okay
john
i'm gonna i'm gonna ask you a different
question you know where is that
uh
so i'm gonna give you a different
scenario
but it's related
if if you
if you are actively consistently
headhunting people
and the consistent response that you got
was john look
sounds really interesting but right now
it's safer to stay put
me moving in the economic downturn in a
challenging market that's too risky like
what again this might have been
something that you experience in covid
so what again what will come up for you
when in terms of navigating a consistent
objection like that that
people might start facing or feeling
with how negative things can be online
yeah no it's a tough objection obviously
we've all had it during covid um i think
there's like probably two ways to look
at it
and the first is if an organization is
hiring through a really tough time like
it probably says something about them if
they're hiring and they've got a run
rate a burn rate to employ their staff
for a number of years and they're in a
market which maybe is recession proof or
covert proof whatever it is then
probably is a bit of a different story
so it's a different sell
i think as well like you've got to
consider
when it's a boom and all the candidates
are looking maybe salaries aren't as
competitive
and perhaps there's a stronger stronger
room for negotiation but i think
ultimately unlike any deal with a
candidate like it's it's not just about
money like dig into the drivers
you know what are you currently happy
with what would it take for you to
consider a move right now
and you know they'll tell you a couple
of things ask another why and then you
start to generally get the truth and
once you understand the candidates
drivers whether it's they want to
progress to leadership whether it's they
want a diverse side and something else
sell different products whatever it is
like you've got something to sell on
they've got an incentive to understand
your call so it's it's about one or two
aspects really but
yeah i take it on that approach
okay so obviously you love that thanks
for sharing that anyway i'm gonna come
to you on this
obviously we we've remained all quite
positive and i absolutely love that i'm
i'm an optimist myself you had some good
views on this didn't you
[Music]
what's um but like so a lot of the
questions that came through were just
like again just just sharing inside
perspective
so from your perspective what do you see
some of the future challenges being
um that people in here may expect that
your team might expect what comes up for
you
we haven't you had to get
i mean look like i said before we don't
know what's around the corner yeah we
are there are murmurs of a potential
recession
i don't know
one of the challenges that we're
experiencing as a team because we do a
lot of international yeah and projects
we've relied really really heavily on
the mobilization of people okay and
since brexit a lot of the eu laws have
just started to kick in over the last
few months so we can no longer send uk
nationals into the likes of scandinavia
central europe without like a 12-week
lead time that's really really expensive
and we relied really really heavily on
that to deliver a lot of our
international business so we're having
to look at alternative solutions to that
and setting up entities in these
different countries changing our
strategy somewhat so i guess in the
immediate horizon they're the challenges
that we're facing
um
in terms of other things
you just don't know do you the thing i
always say though if you're great at
recruitment you can apply it to any
sector in any industry it's a process at
the end of the day yeah that's one of
the beauties about this job is it's so
fluid you can become a master at
recruitment whether that's permanent
retained contract projects whatever it
might be
if your sector and your industry has a
downturn which happens
we've been there recently
if you're good at your job you can apply
it to a new sector and you can be
successful so there's always going to be
a challenge there's always going to be
something and if it is a downturn you
just need to move into a sector that
isn't
our biggest challenge is finding good
people to be honest both for our own
business
and for our clients as well
and and that right now is is the main
challenge that as a business we're
really trying to overcome okay
so again we can't predict the future
obviously i like the answer
so again to keep all of you you guys
included in this i guess again a bit of
an opportunity here to
talk about things that we may have
missed challenges that maybe you feel
like might be more strongly about that
might be around the corner we can talk
about them so again
please do do share these in terms of
what are you most concerned about going
into the next six to 12 months
depending on what gets shared here we
can again talk about this and then we'll
do
some actual q and a make sure you guys
are getting your questions answered and
have uh any specific questions for you
guys we'll answer them but
let's have a look at this thing guys and
see what
what what we're missing what challenges
maybe we haven't thought about or maybe
people were putting more importance on
yes the candidates not wanting to move
you to the economic downturn
they've obviously touched on that with
john
companies putting a freeze on
recruitment
the unknown of yes i mean that you were
saying that weren't you in terms of
the unknown of if your market is going
to continue to be busy
what things do you look for in that when
it comes to
the actual [ __ ] here now
it's just getting it's kind of i'll put
it back on i can answer don't worry yeah
so the ques the question to amy there is
like what what things can we look at
right now in terms of that that's going
to give us confidence that our markets
are recession proof that there are
future proof if things do start
tightening up like what because
obviously you've made some moves and
refocused didn't you so what is it that
you you look for it's re it's really
really simple job numbers that's it
job numbers
per head that that's the only metric
really as long as all the inputs are
there um in terms of business
conversations data
leads meetings all of that the inputs
if job numbers are down you need to look
at who you ring in first and is there a
training issue if there's not and it's
consistent across the entire team then
there's a potential there that there's
going to be a little bit of a downturn
and actually it's my job or anyone who's
in a senior job to
make those decisions early before it
becomes a problem yeah so job job flow
is like the number one absolutely really
really simple ev every single week my
number two my two things i look for
interviews per day jobs per day that's
it interviews per day jobs per day
solid
um carl how do you feel about this the
one i'm going to come to is
having to potentially navigate cost
reductions if client budgets get tighter
i don't know how you feel about that
what
how how would you navigate clients
saying look carl we've given you a lot
of business
you've seen it's got a bit tighter
what can you do what can you do in your
your fees can you reduce them i don't
know what how how how are you going to
be navigating that if that comes up for
you
well i guess that depends how bad it
gets mate to be honest with you
i think i think look
broadly speaking right if you if you
back yourself and your service
then
as amy said before like you know most
companies for some reason think that the
more work they give you
the more the bigger the cheaper
you should give i think with that again
it depends how bad it is in terms of the
situation but the conversations that we
have start to span longer term yeah so
like the questions that i ask on a on a
call
you know the market's good so everyone's
hiring in multiples but i'll try to look
12 months ahead so okay
how many of these people are within this
team or within this unit do you think
you're going to need to hire in the next
12 months
because then you can start to pitch
bigger longer term you know more
strategic revenue yeah and then it
allows you to bring the conversation
back to say well look we can do
something on the cost but we need more
commitment for it from you
okay nice
don't let anything for you on that
um now that's a really good point so um
i just think basically with a client
sometimes
it depends on the situation you are
sometimes you have to let them fail um
you know when clients come to us and you
know we charge the margins
and the charge reduces and say like look
at the value of our service rather than
the cost of it so you know you're
arguing over a few grand all right it's
quite a lot in your budget but
it you know it's not like everybody in
the world can deliver the same service
so
i think if you get to the point and you
add loads of value and you can get the
client see the value in a different
position and then if they ask you for
cost reduction
no problem help me understand your hires
over the next year and then you're in a
different negotiation point of view let
me put it as a project and all of a
sudden you've you're doing a discovery
and you're asking requirements
you're in a completely different ball
game
love it so let's move this on then to
questions from you uh lovely lot i feel
like this is a
quite i know we've spoken a lot about
the uh the next 6-12 months
but i think this is a bit more specific
on amy i'm going to come to you on this
i know you love the day plan sorry i'm
putting on the spot
uh
so question is from jenna
after the news that we're entering a
recession
what would you advise to
what does that say would you advise to
add into a daily plan that would help
avoid being affected by it
yeah so i think the key thing there is
you need to have a day plan so event
obviously i said it a lot in my podcast
always always planned the night before
it's so so important i think look if
there's a potential of that you've got
to spread the risk so you need to be
adding as much data as possible reaching
out to as many clients as possible in
your market but really really honing
down on a niche again don't
pick up jobs that aren't in your market
because you'll end up being a bit of a
jack-of-all-trades and you're not going
to be famous for anything our chairman
his big big thing is what are you famous
for what are you famous for because if
there is a recession but you are the
go-to person you're not going to be
affected by it because you're going to
still pick up business because you're
the expert in that field so stay
disciplined stick to what you know
become a master provide an amazing
service
with the clients that you're working
with and continually try and win new
business in the same area
and you should i'm saying it won't
affect you but i think it'll affect you
as little as possible
john i'm going to come to you on this
one
question from millie
when hiring new talent for your teams
what is your biggest red flag
in the candidate hiring in my internal
yeah
that's the biggest red flag
great question
you get
yeah red flag that you're like no
done
interview um
it's a good it's a good point i probably
have on the flip side a number of things
i do look for yeah but if something was
like a turn off for me it's just
somebody who's who's got
no like longerity with something like
okay show me some commitment show me
something you've done for a while that's
taken a little bit of pain and you've
got some reward like
you know if you've always started some
and sucked it off i'm like well
you've got no persistence to grit about
you really so i think in recruitment
especially if you were to go in a bad
time and i don't know if we will
you know if you've not got that
persistence and grit about you like
what's going to happen in the bad times
um so i think for me that would be like
a bit of a turn off carl biggest red
flag
what do you look for here we go
oh so you have your own business so you
you must have i'm sure you have
there's going to be a few things maybe
so i think there's probably a couple of
things here so
similar to john in some instances but um
i think adaptability is a massive thing
adaptability yeah so something that
isn't adaptable would be a red flag yeah
so like when you try and probe around
that people that are like stuck in the
ways don't want to learn new things like
especially with the markets evolving the
way we are you know we're talking about
entering a recession or whatever the
case may be so i think that's massive
the other thing which
we've seen quite a lot of over the last
12 months is people slagging off their
old employer wow and i think that's
pretty [ __ ] to be honest with you like
you know our but it doesn't matter how
bad it is like just yeah
don't spend the hour conversation with
me 55 minutes telling me how [ __ ] they
are
what what i take from that because this
has come up a lot is like basically
they're not taking responsibility
accountability
and that's
easy to point the finger
okay milly great question
uh what we've got here from rio what
have you found da da da i feel like
actually i'm gonna come to you on this
one
more specific about new market so
what have you found most effective when
winning new business when entering a new
market so maybe think about
when you're really trying to kick on in
the renewable energy space what ended up
being the most effective way to build
that
it all starts with the beginning of the
life cycle which is candidates if you've
got the best people you can break into
clients even if they've got other
suppliers a psl
whatever if you've got the best people
they they can't ignore you so get the
candidates on board first work with some
fantastic people market them out to
multiple clients
and eventually clients will start to
work with you
john i know you've been obviously
building traction in the in the us
what what have you found to be a most
effective approach when building out
that new market you think what what have
you found going [ __ ] i know what that
that's really working or that continues
to to be the best way to to build new
relationships and in this new market
uh yeah i think that's that's a really
broad question isn't it because you've
got the client and candidate piece and
like i take it back a couple of
questions ago where i was like we've got
i need a type of client we specifically
go after yeah
and there's like a few of us in the
business who do business development and
we have different verticals within us
but once we get that client on it's just
about delivering and because the client
might grow and we'll grow with them
about
expanding the accounts um
and i think for us you know
two years ago when i joined the business
it was like very job-led you get a job
and there's an abundance of candidates
to go out to market with and and now
maybe it's evened up a little bit so
to attract top talent is extremely hard
and to attract like the kind of
businesses we specifically want to work
for is is equally as hard okay um so
it's just about having that exact
strategy not having a
and coming back to being famous for
something like that yeah yeah yeah
i reiterate with amy really
love that so i think we've got one more
here before
we then go to people can submit them so
colin i come to you on this one it was a
question from nick
i like this one
carl what one career mistake would you
like to go back and correct
i've had some absolute stinkers mate
if you could pick one
um
be honest
so basically yeah who's here
um
so it's a funny story so all right once
upon a time right yeah way back when
when i first started contract
i got a bit of intel off this like
really senior guy and i was like right
this is this is mega like it was on the
inside of a big tech business right so
basically i took that information
mail shouted out to a load of clients
thinking right they're going to be like
all over it right because like i'm in
the know before they are
and it turns out that this information
might not have been as reliable as it
ought to be
which resulted in
uh
sap
basically trying to sue the business
that i've worked for
um
that that's that's probably
i mean you know
they took
yeah
hey i look right listen they told me
it's a mail shot so that's what you get
right i mean
that's what you get for mail shotting so
yeah
thanks for sharing that
amy
what one career mistake would be no i'm
like looking at my team like help me
you can think of a few okay come on
um
i don't know i mean there's just so many
isn't there
every mistake is a lesson learned
i honestly don't know there's been a lot
there's been a lot i think yeah
you have to make mistakes to get back
can you think of something go on
hiring him
[Laughter]
right doesn't work for me anymore
amy you have a all right can you come
back to me
john help me what one career mistake
would you like to go back and correct my
friend uh i mean i've made a lot but i
think probably one of the biggest ones
up there was
um i was a recruiter with like nine
months experience at the time yeah i
picked up a worldly candidate yeah and i
[ __ ] specked them into their own job
[Laughter]
yeah it didn't go down too well yeah
but now
amy all right yeah
we agree we can learn from mistakes but
we want the mistake i think yeah sit not
too far far off what john's just said
okay very very new was passed a job when
i started
rang
the manager that was hiring as a
candidate to pitch the job to him and he
said to me
well i'm actually the person that's
hiring so it gives me absolutely no hope
that you have a clue what you're doing
and that you can feel this job but i
went on to place about 20 people with
him in the answer
all right thanks for sharing thanks for
the inspiration
um so look before we before we finish
then a wrap up here again
using this technology that has been
hasn't been perfect so what you can do
with this
is you can type anything let's keep it
let's keep it adult let's not go rogue
but
there's some
as we wrap up here let's give it like
five five minutes or so
you guys can put any questions on here
it is anonymous
and they'll show up on
here i have a longer [ __ ] here now
all right let's see what happens
okay so we got tell me more about your
record quarter let's definitely not
[ __ ] answer that
uh
okay nice amy i know you you touched on
this
being obviously the only [ __ ] woman
on the stage what like
yeah talk to us like
you're up here with three guys
you've you've built a career in a highly
competitive environment which is
typically surrounded by men
talk to me why like what would you say
to women wanting to get into recruitment
do do they have the edge
i would say
do it it's it's yeah i never really knew
what recruitment was when i got into it
to be honest but i couldn't imagine
doing anything else now i think
it it's definitely seen as more of a
male-dominated industry i think that
that is starting to change
when you think about the skill set
required to be successful in recruitment
it's about building relationships
understanding people reading between the
lines having a really high level of
emotional intelligence being
conscientious
detail-oriented organized so many of
these things lend themselves to a
typical female profile
that i think gets overlooked because
everybody just assumes it's this like
really hot and heavy dog eat dog sales
job which of course it is at times
but really it's not about that and
there's some really really incredible
successful females in recruitment and i
just would want to encourage anybody to
get into it and those females that are
in it to get your friends to to do it as
well because i just think there's so
many characteristics that typically lend
themselves to a female
that are natural that will help you be
successful okay love it
right
right we might be a bit longer than five
minutes we've got some belter questions
in here so i want to make sure we get
through
so
kyle before besides getting sued
what did you get what did you do
differently
to everyone else in your business that
led you to where you are you think what
do you do differently
like this question
so i think i came from a very
traditional background kind of similar
to to both
amy and john um
i think the thing that
probably put me in the position i am
today is i was just willing to try
different things
quite early on so like things like
events things like podcasts i you know
2018 i started doing that stuff i think
that's the thing that probably
helped me to go
to go differently um
okay other than that before that i was
just doing
same as everyone else like smashing the
numbers so uh john commented on this one
advice for someone who lacks confidence
in their ability
thanks for sharing that whoever shared
that um
a couple of things really that comes
straight to mind um i'll start off with
probably the most recent one so you know
our our directors are really good enough
that they they invest a lot in the
business um
and i think when you look at recruitment
the reality is it's like
four or five percent training and 95 on
the sales whereas i look at like the top
athletes in the world football teams
tennis players they spend ninety six
seven percent of the time training the
reality is like a couple couple of
percent game time
um i've invested a bit in you know life
coach recently a guy called chris oil
like highly recommend him help him with
not just like you know your sales aspect
but your mental health your thinking
and so if you're lacking confidence i
think there's a strong network in
manchester never mind just recruitment
that you can reach out to and there's
you know there's people like yourself
with great contacts that i'm sure you
would put consultants in touch with so i
think after the battle is like reaching
out and then once you do reach out and
you have a few chats you build your
confidence and you're on your first
stepping stone there
love it
uh
amy
come and shoot with this one
how do you stay motivated when you're at
the top
i don't know i always just feel like
for me
i have a real fear of failure
so
that's what motivates me personally is
the fear of failing or losing drives me
harder than the like motivation of being
the best so for me personally that's
what it is but i think
in general it's just about always
remembering your why why are you doing
what you're doing what are your goals
and if you can always remember that and
your why is bigger than what it takes to
get there you'll always be at the top
whether that's the top of the business
or just at the top of where you want to
be that's what i'll keep you there love
it
uh
kyle
i think i've been calling you carl all
night have you
basically is your name carl kyle
kyle okay
ky
you've got a [ __ ] flyer on your seat
um
right i had a question right here we go
so i'll come to this one for you kyle
big biggest challenge when converting
contingency recruitment to retained and
how to overcome
i was having this conversation with john
before so we we've been really lucky in
obviously starting the business
september 2020 we started as we were
only going to do retained so when you
start something like that
that's the model you go with that's what
you're pitching that's that's all you
know and you're not going to deviate
from that
i imagine it's really difficult when
you've got clients that are used to
working with your contingent um
to try and convert that but i think
you know we i managed to do it
previously and before us before i set up
um
pretty well again it was with new
clients that necessarily didn't know any
different um
but i think
i mean you've got to play to the to the
advantage of the market at the minute
right so if the market's good candidates
are hard to come by you know you've got
to lean on things like they get first
reviews along candidates
um you know all of that type of stuff
where you're going to focus time energy
and resource into that sorry but what
about i feel like when i speak to people
about this the most common objection
that they share with me is
kyle we've always worked contingency
while i won't be retained
um
again mate for me and this is difficult
for me to answer because a lot of our
work comes inbound
so when it comes inbound it's really you
know you're on your terms right yeah
you've got the leverage right look
you've come to me this is how we work
yeah um
all right sorry i wasn't much used to
that was it uh i thought this is an
interesting one in the past two years a
lot of vacancies have been remote
working are you now struggling with
getting candidates to get back to
face-to-face or hybrid working and how
are you dealing with that john i'm going
to come to you with that one
um
yeah i mean i think it's reality a lot
of bigger businesses went remote and
that that's great oh wait yeah sorry
sorry
so apparently it's just not me
sorry
yeah i think a lot of a lot of
businesses went remote and a lot of
bigger businesses did but i've always
worked in an office where it's mainly
office led and if you need to work from
home you can do um i'm a little bit
old-school in the sense of like i
appreciate the buzz of an office like i
like going out for the guys and girls
with the beer after work so
um whilst i think working remote is
important it'll probably gather a lot
more attraction over the next few years
it's
i haven't had much personal experience
so how have you dealt with candidates
though saying like look john i like i'm
i won this job but i want to fully
remind you are we on about recruitment
sorry
about counting wrong about candidates so
question is if you're if you're speaking
to candidates about jobs your client is
they want to be in they want them to be
in the office yeah thursday they're
going [ __ ] off john i want it fully
remote yeah no that's fair so that's
just taking your simple job spec your
job brief like you negotiate on every
part of the job spec you know the salary
like if i had an a-star candidate would
do this
you know if i had an a-star candidate
met the brief would you allow them two
days working so you're just kind of
pushing your boundaries when you take a
job spec really and that's when you'll
know and if if they don't have any flex
then don't even bother with the
candidate
right we're gonna do two more questions
and then we'll wrap it up so i think
we've spoken a lot about this so let me
uh just bring this up which is
what you guys do differently
sorry two seconds let's do it awesome
right we spoke about this a lot
amy what comes up for you on this why do
you think there is such a challenge in
hiring good talent in manchester
because there's so many recruitment
companies
yeah um
yeah i think that there are a lot of
recruitment companies in manchester i
feel like outside of london it's
probably the the biggest place there's
also a lot of really good companies as
well that offer really great evps
benefits incentives and things like that
i also think as well
you can attract them but what it takes
to be successful in recruitment is it's
really difficult so you get a lot of
people who think they want it
and
they genuinely do but then when when it
comes to it that they don't and it does
take a certain type of character
to
to make it in recruitment so i think
that that adds to it as well so we have
a really really rigorous
um internal recruitment process
to try and obviously make us
you know take the risk out of the
decision as much as possible but i think
ultimately there's a lot of careers out
there recruitment isn't necessarily
something people go to uni and think i
want to be a recruiter you tend to fall
into it it's a lot of competition and
it's a really hard job and i think a
combination of all of those things
together
is what makes it so challenging
okay so i think we're going to end on
this one
john do your stand-up comedy sketch
[Applause]
i i have no i didn't i didn't ask the
question come on john do you actually
have a comedy sketch nah nah we had a
guy in today and he was like doing us on
public speaking and we had to tell a
joke and like mine is not appropriate
and i'm not doing that
[Applause]
categorically and i'm doing it
um well look i think look let's end it
there i think i just want to say
um massive let's put her hands together
for kyle
but amy
john
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks to all you lovely lot for coming